we collect special interest stuff you
know there's always that special
interest section that's that's what we
want I want you to look at all of those
Wiggles then we have one video called
rent a friend it's a guy who will be
your friend for forty-five insane
minutes he'll ask you a question he'll
leave a space for you to answer and then
he has a conversation with you I want to
be your friend
how's that sound great I'm Joe this is
Nick this is our collection here a VHS
tape yeah we've been collecting for 26
years
these are old videos that weren't meant
to be shown in public so they're things
like exercise videos that's a little
category but within that we've got a
section called earth-sized which are all
videos that had the word earth-sized in
it so it'd be like protector size with
self-defense exercise videos we have a
whole section over there of scarf tying
videos there's a whole row of all videos
on how to tie a scarf we have a category
called unusually specific and that's all
stuff like we have one called how to
identify and machine-made marbles and
it's like what three people in the world
was that VHS tape made we want how to
spot counterfeit beanie babies yeah like
I guess there was a problem in early 90s
I was just rampant it's a needle in a
haystack to find something that's good
in the right way we have some rules like
it has to be unintentionally funny we
have to find it physically in hand I
mean we put too many restrictions on
ourselves but when you find something
that's gold you can't wait to show it
off to people
VHS officially died in 2007 the last
plant that made VHS tapes a mass scale
yeah they're gone now so everything is
at thrift stores now okay yeah so a lot
of movies but I think if you dig deep
enough there's some other stuff here
just gotta look through every single
thing Oh white tape let's see that with
Barney's definitely how many Land Before
Time released you think there were
including straight-to-video
4 14 14 14 yep I know why I was looking
that up in 1991 I was working at a
McDonald's in my hometown and my friend
was training to become a manager there
and had to watch 30 different videos on
how to do everything at McDonald's and
he told me to come into the break room
one day because there's a video called
inside and outside custodial duties and
I watched it with him that day and I
could not believe how profoundly stupid
it was and my thought was this can't
stay in the break room like Joe needs to
see this finesse that wall
that's the way make a giant guy make it
shine
that became like a regular video we
would screen on a Friday night and we'd
had this running commentary of jokes and
that just got us thinking there has to
be more videos like this like right
under our noses and out-of-the-way
places oh yeah I think we got a winner
here Calvin Klein men fall 1993 so if
that's some kind of fashion show and
this is vintage 1997 so this one is I'm
most excited about another one another
one balloon of co2 the sequels remember
is good but oh look at the guy oh we
have other videos of this game cool we
have not even come close to watching
every single tape here I think that we
probably watched what 35% yeah a third
maybe because it was a unique moment in
time for a technology it reached market
saturation everybody had a VCR at one
point and it was so cheap to produce VHS
and that's why you got all these weird
esoteric things ending up on tape how
much my VHS see good price good price
yeah we've been doing the the touring
show for 14 years now it's Nick and I
giving a guided tour of our latest
greatest finds but we used to do it you
know my parents living room or our
college dorm room apartments and now
we're able to do that all over the world
I think about three years into it for me
I think that my parents were confused
like how I made money now they're just
like okay he has this weird job and I
think it's harder to explain to like
aunts and uncles who are just like so
what are you doing it's like sit down
and say yeah it's hard to say my
grandparents went to their graves not
understanding what I did I think 10 year
old me if he came into this room and saw
everything he'd be like you made it it
all paid off did it yeah I tip my head
and older Joe we just don't know how to
do anything else we really don't have
the answer this is our skillset we're in
way too deep yeah
[Music]